[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
All right, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm here with Chuck Gaidica.
Chuck, thanks for being with us.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Good to see you.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yeah.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Thank you.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Yeah, great to see you.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Thanks very much.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: I'll
give a short introduction
for those who aren't local
Detroit fans already.
CHUCK GAIDICA: All right.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Chuck works
at WDIV Channel 4 in Detroit.
Has been there
for 30-plus years.
Worked on all
sorts of programs--
Thanksgiving Day Parade,
Stanley Cup coverage,
NHL Winter Classic.
You name it.
Pretty much any big event
that's happening in the Greater
Detroit area, Chuck has been
involved in through the media.
He's also a co-host
and backup anchor
for Al Roker on the
weekend "Today Show."
CHUCK GAIDICA:
Yeah, I have been.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Correct?
CHUCK GAIDICA:
That's kind of past.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
You have been, yeah.
CHUCK GAIDICA: But
yeah, I've been--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: In the past.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Mm-hm.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Worked nationally
with all sorts of organizations,
including National Geographic.
Done some expeditions
with them--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah,
Dr. Bob Ballard--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
--I understand.
CHUCK GAIDICA: --the guy who
discovered the "Titanic."
So I got to be with him on--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA:
--two expeditions,
one to the rain forest
in Peru for 10 days,
and one to the top
of Mount Kilauea.
Very cool stuff.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Were
there any dangerous moments
in those expeditions?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah,
the smallest thing--
an ant called the bullet ant.
It looks like a big
chunky black ant.
And I saw a scrawny camp dog
jump and get out of the way.
And I asked my guide.
I said, why did that dog just
jump out of the way of the ant?
He said, oh, it's the
law of the jungle.
If that ant bites us, it's
equivalent to 38 bee stings.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yikes.
CHUCK GAIDICA: And so I stayed
clear of them myself, too.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: [CHUCKLES]
CHUCK GAIDICA: It was good.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: OK, yeah,
if the dog's scared of an ant.
CHUCK GAIDICA:
Yeah, I'd just watch
where the dog wasn't
going, and I'd just-- yeah,
I went with him, yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: OK.
So, Chuck, during all this
time you spent in the industry,
are there any periods of
those 30-plus years that were
your favorite,
where you could say,
I really miss the '90s or--
[CHUCKLING]
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Any--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah, I've been
through a lot of decades, yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Yeah, tell us about that.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, I
started about '80-ish.
So I've been in the
business almost 38 years.
So I started down south.
I grew up in Chicago--
never worked there;
almost went there--
and wound up starting
in a small market.
In television, what we used
to call broadcasting-- now
everything is media.
But in the day, you always
started in a small market.
And you worked your way up.
And I started out
to be a dentist--
a doctor.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Oh wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Got
to Loyola University.
Loved the idea, but I
was programmed as a kid
I should be a doctor.
Nothing against
doctors, by the way.
But I dropped out in the first
half of my first semester.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: So
I kid my children
that I'm able to operate
on them with a spork.
That's about all I can do--
plastic.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: And
you have a child that's
becoming a doctor now, correct?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, a
different kind of doctor.
Right here in Ann Arbor.
He'll have a doctorate
in neuroscience.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Researcher.
So he's working on
Parkinson's, which
is just the coolest thing.
I mean, he is on fire to
find a cure for Parkinson's.
So it's a lot of fun.
So I started there.
Moved very quickly early on.
Nine months in my first job.
I met my wife there.
Got fired on purpose.
Called her up and said,
meet me at my townhouse.
She did.
I had nothing.
I had a bicycle.
And I don't remember if I had
the love seat or the sofa.
My buddy and I moved
together from college,
and so we were roommates.
So I got the sofa, the bicycle,
and I think I had a table.
And I got down on one knee.
And I said, would you marry me?
I have nothing.
I didn't even have a ring.
[CHUCKLING]
Basically, it was an IOU.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Oh, OK.
CHUCK GAIDICA: And we'll be
married 36 years next month.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: 7/11--
I remember that now because
we get free Slurpees.
[CHUCKLING]
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Congratulations.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Thank you, yeah,
on the Slurpee or the wedding?
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Both.
CHUCK GAIDICA: And so
then I move really quick.
And I got to Detroit.
I don't know if anybody here
will remember back in the day,
there was a weather guy
here named Sonny Eliot.
And he was probably, when
I got here, about 65-ish.
And I was this young
whippersnapper from down south.
I got the job.
I didn't know him.
And so that's how
I got to Detroit.
Channel 2 was CBS
back in the day.
Worked there for five years.
Went to work for the network.
Substituted for two years in New
York on the CBS Morning News,
all the while still living here.
And then Channel
4 heard that I was
thinking of jumping to Chicago.
They said, no, you're not.
And I went to work at Channel 4.
And that was almost
to the month--
next month August, it will
be 30 years at Channel 4.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
Congratulations.
CHUCK GAIDICA: So crazy.
I mean, it just--
[SNAPS] just went as fast
as the first couple three.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Are there others
at Channel 4 that have
been there 30 years?
CHUCK GAIDICA: No, I think--
and I'm just part time
now because I left,
and I came back.
It's kind of like the mafia.
You're never allowed to leave.
So no, I think I
may have tenure.
I think I'm the guy, yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Oh.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Great.
What brought you into the
industry in the first place?
I mean, being a weatherman
would be fun, I imagine--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
--for anybody.
CHUCK GAIDICA: So I
drop out of school.
I go to work at
Walgreens drugstore,
trying to figure out what
I'm going to do with my life
because now I'm this guy
with a lot of great grades
and a free ride to Loyola.
But I've just told
my parents, sorry,
I don't want to be a doctor.
It didn't go over too well.
And so I went to
work at Walgreens.
I'm trying to figure out how do
I take my interest in science
and math, which I loved
and I was strong at,
and how do I take my
interest in journalism
and put them together?
So I came up with meteorology.
And I transferred to
Southern Illinois University,
where they had a program--
not a major-- in meteorology.
Left there with
this buddy of mine,
and we went to interview for
a job in Evansville, Indiana.
And I was qualified to
either be a TV news reporter,
or I could do the weather.
I had enough training.
And so he went in for
the interview first.
There were two job
openings-- a TV reporter
and a TV weatherman,
five days a week.
And so he went in first, and he
comes out with a big thumbs up
like, I got this one.
And so they call
me in, sit me down.
In those days we had tapes.
And they put my
tape in the machine.
They watched my tape of me
doing reporting and weather.
And they said, we
like your tape.
We're going to offer
you either job.
And I already knew I
wanted the weather job
because I could get trained by
the National Weather Service.
So I said, well, how
much do they pay?
The general manager said,
well, the reporter job
is $10,000 a year.
And the weather guy
is $15,000 a year.
I said, [CLAPS] I'm
your new weather guy.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Yeah, easy decision, huh?
CHUCK GAIDICA: So that's
the way it started.
And then I did get trained
by the Weather Service.
So I was able to forecast and
work with the computer models.
And so I've got degrees
that are different.
I've got a master's now.
So I have varied interests.
But weather was the
interest at the beginning.
Still is every day, even
though I don't do it every day.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: OK.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: So weather
is your primary interest.
You've also been a game show
host for the "Michigan Lottery
Show."
CHUCK GAIDICA: That was
kind of by accident.
I auditioned three times for the
"Michigan Lottery Game Show."
It was seen in nine
markets in the state.
And I thought, oh, this
isn't going to work.
I mean, what are the odds?
And I had been called by a
group out of California, Barry
& Enright Productions, to
audition for "The Joker's Wild"
and for another game show.
And I didn't want to
move to California.
It didn't make sense
for my family's life.
So I auditioned.
Two or three of these
auditions, and by that time,
I was getting a little upset.
I thought, hey, if you
want me, you want me.
And if you don't, it's OK.
I got stuff to do.
And they said, sure, how
would you like to do it?
We'll tape every Friday.
And I thought it would be like
a one-year flash in the pan.
It was 12 years.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: So
worked out fine.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That was fun?
CHUCK GAIDICA: And I got to
give people $50,000 a week
and a car or a cruise.
And I thought, what a country?
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
People love you.
CHUCK GAIDICA: What
a country, you know?
[CHUCKLING]
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Oh, that's great.
Tell us a little bit
more about your career
and how you've adapted and
changed your personal brand
over the past 38 years.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well,
in recent time,
we've used that phrase
"personal brand."
I don't know that I ever
thought of it that way.
But it's been described
to me as a brand.
So for me, I started
to get a little knock
on the door in my 40s.
I think it happens
to some people
maybe earlier in their
30s, but in my 40s.
And the knock on the door
was not midlife crisis,
like I needed a
Corvette or something.
It was, why am I here?
What am I doing?
Is this all there is--
those kinds of questions.
So I got a hold of a
book called "Halftime--
Moving Your Life from
Success to Significance."
And I thought, man, [SNAPS]
that resonates with me.
I thought I was always
a good guy, you know.
I like to do good for people.
But I thought, yeah,
that really resonates.
So I started really
thinking about this idea.
What am I going to do?
So as I was looking at
that, I thought, well,
now I may have an issue in terms
of a personal brand or a story,
like is this authentic?
And it was, and it is.
And so for me, that
was the beginning
of this journey of trying
to figure out, well,
what am I going to
do when I grow up?
And I think we go through
that in various stages.
I remember in my late 30s to
early 40s asking questions
that I asked myself
when I was 10.
I grew up in the
inner city of Chicago.
Sitting on a back porch,
concrete backyard--
a little bit of grass lawn--
looking up at the stars,
wondering one night,
why am I here?
Is there a god?
What am I supposed
to do when I grow up?
Who will I marry?
You know, all the big questions.
And then you fast
forward into my 40s.
And I'm asking, why am I here?
Is there a god?
What am I supposed
to do when I grow up?
You know, I'm married,
and it's all working out.
So I didn't have
to ask that one.
But that whole idea of what am
I going to do when I grow up
was a really
interesting question.
I was flying at the top of
my game in broadcasting.
But yet I felt like there was
going to be something more.
And more didn't mean better.
More didn't mean more money.
More to me was, what can I do?
I guess success to
significance resonates.
But for me, that
was the question.
What can I do to help people?
And so that's when life
started to shift for me.
It's very interesting.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: And what
steps did you take next?
I understand you went to
Jerusalem and other parts--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: --of the
world to discover yourself
and learn more about your faith.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, I
went back for a masters.
I went back for a master's
in ministry and leadership.
I'm a student of leadership.
So I like that
idea of wondering,
how do you walk
alongside people?
How do you motivate them?
I mean, I'm in your building.
And I'm watching, how do
you keep this group moving?
And what's going on?
And it's not by accident
that I got a free latte.
I mean, it's like, wow, I'm
motivated now, you know.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Yeah, a good one, too.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah,
it's a good one.
So that began.
Part of my journey was to
go live in Israel and Jordan
for a month.
So I studied on the ground.
Covered archeology and
history of the Bible.
So that was a
reinforcing thing for me.
And then I was invited--
I actually put on a conference.
900 baby boomers showed up.
And I had a speaker come in
from the Halftime Institute.
The same man who wrote the book
took his wealth and decided he
was going to target it toward
doing good by inspiring
what he would describe, I
guess, as high-capacity men
and women who maybe are
at that stage like I was.
What am I going to do now?
And then coach them-- come
alongside and send them out
into the world.
Go do good.
So I went to this
intensive three-day thing
out at Pepperdine
University in Malibu.
I don't know how kids
go to school in Malibu.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
It's beautiful.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Oh my gosh.
You walk out, and
there's the ocean.
I'm thinking, I would
slack off all the time.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That's your motivation
to stay there-- stay in school.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Right, I'm
a six-year freshman, yeah.
So I go out to Malibu.
And I'm in this three-day
intensive with coaches who had
walked away from their jobs.
Multi-billion-dollar
operations is what they led.
And there were only 10 of us.
And they're coaching
me on what do you
want to do when you grow up?
What is that going to look like?
What is success to significance?
What are your strengths?
What are your weaknesses?
So it was a fascinating
part of the journey.
So I come back now, and
I've got a certificate
in second-half significance.
The irony, of
course, is I'm still
trying to figure out my own.
So it's still part
of the journey.
And I think the other part of
this that maybe would resonate
was when I started to go
through these feelings,
I had to make sure that
my spouse was on track.
And at the beginning,
she did not
understand these feelings I had.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Did she think you
were having a midlife crisis?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Maybe at--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: My
wife would say that.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah, I think
at the beginning, she did.
And then I coined a phrase
that really helped me.
It was lethargic for
me, and it helped me.
I would tell her, and I would
tell my kids if they asked--
and anybody that asked--
I'm having the most
fun being confused
I've ever had in my life.
Now part of that was
because I could be confused
at that stage in my life.
And I still had a great job.
But I knew I was
looking for what's next.
And so that unfolded over
the course of about a decade.
And I wound up
getting my master's.
By the time I was done, I
got my master's at age 54.
So I'm on track to
get a PhD when I'm 90.
So--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: All right.
CHUCK GAIDICA: --you
know, it's never too late.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Oh, that's great.
What are some of
the steps we can
take to find significance
or move from success
to significance?
Anything that we could maybe--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
--leave today and think
about doing ourselves?
CHUCK GAIDICA:
Well, I think that--
there are people that
have different views.
Steve Harvey just wrote
a book called "Jump."
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Mm-hm.
CHUCK GAIDICA:
And his premise is
that sometimes we think about
this idea of doing things.
It may not even be
goodness, right?
It may just be a job.
And we think about it.
We pray about it.
We do about it.
And then we just get paralyzed.
We don't move.
So one of the premises
anyway of his book is jump.
Just take a chance, and
lean into your strengths.
And there are some
that would say,
you should analyze
your strengths.
I think that's a good idea.
You know, Gallup
"StrengthsFinder," $15.
You can get your
top five strengths.
And I've been told by
world-class coaches that
probably in your lifetime,
maybe your sixth strength
will cycle in.
But basically your top five
are your top five strengths
for your lifetime.
Well, that's good to
know what I'm good at.
But if you look at the
YouTube videos or Vimeo--
wherever they are--
it will also show you red flags.
Be careful.
So in my case, my top
strength is I'm a learner.
I love to learn stuff.
But I don't know if you
noticed, when I walked in,
I went and looked at the camera.
Like, who makes it?
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Mm-hm, right.
CHUCK GAIDICA: What brand is it?
That's a downside for me.
So I'm a learner,
but, like, I want
to look at the bottom
of my latte cup.
Did that come from China?
Who makes that paper?
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: You
get distracted or pulled--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah, yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: --in
a lot of directions.
CHUCK GAIDICA: So, I mean,
it's good to know that though,
because then I know
that I shouldn't
be looking at
bright, shiny objects
because they can distract me.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: I imagine
that makes your career
a good fit for you, hosting
a morning talk show because--
CHUCK GAIDICA: Being a learner?
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Being a learner
because the variety of people
that come in is enormous.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Right.
Well, we've got live guests.
We've got live animals.
I mean, we've got
all kinds of stuff.
So it's from people who
are important to people
who think they're important.
[CHUCKLING]
And I've met both.
And so it's fun because
there is variety.
In my case, I keep retiring.
So I'm going to keep retiring
until I get it right.
And so my goal now is really
to focus my energy and my being
on doing good.
And so for me, there's a
Biblical charge to that.
But there's also an idea that
I really want to do good.
And what's interesting
is when you
look at research
from Pew and Barna
and other sources,
millennials and baby
boomers, which is what I am--
I'm a boomer--
show up similarly.
We want to go do.
We want to change the world.
We don't mind travel.
So I think that there
are some differences.
But I'm encouraged that
while the baby boomers--
there are certain statistics
associated with us.
The millennials have just passed
us in terms of sheer numbers.
But there's still
73 million boomers
and locked up between now and
the year 2030, $55 trillion
of saved and inherited wealth
in the hands of boomers.
So the difference is we
may all want to go out
today and go build a
Habitat for Humanity house.
It's just the boomers
will climb the same ladder
and want to put up the shingles.
But we'll say,
hey, you know what?
This is so cool.
Let me write a
check for a grand.
I'll pay for the shingles.
Millennials haven't
gotten there yet.
But we actually show up,
interestingly enough,
with similar loves and
desires about what we
want to do to change the world.
It's really cool.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That's great.
Do you feel like in your current
role in program television
you have opportunity to
serve as much as you'd like?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Probably
not, not just because it's--
I think I can give a
platform to serving.
Maybe I can be an
encourager or more--
how shall I put
it?-- a catalyst.
I'm not some guru.
But I do like to do.
I mean, I like to be
on the ground doing it.
I don't like to just
be talking about it.
So for me, I love adventure.
It's one of the reasons
I became a private pilot.
A lot of things
because of the media
I've gotten to do over
the course of my career.
So I love to be
hands-on and go do.
So I may have to shift
that a little bit in time
to allow me to go do.
And doing-- especially
doing good--
doesn't always pay well.
But for me, that's OK.
I think there are so many
things going on in the world
that I'd like to be
part of and go do.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That's great.
Yeah, keep inspiring us.
And we watch--
CHUCK GAIDICA: I hope.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yeah, good.
I understand being
in program television
that your success of your career
depends highly on your ratings.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
How have you been
able to hold people's attention
as a television broadcaster?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well,
that's changing
right before our very eyes
because what is media?
We could do it on
the iPhone right now.
So I think broadcast
television--
traditional radio
and television--
we all know what's going on.
Let's say I've got five
kids under the age of 35.
Only one of them owns
or pays for cable--
only one.
So I think the
cat's out of the bag
in terms of what's happening
in the world in terms
of on-demand, streaming,
and all the rest of it.
So you guys know that better
than anybody in this building.
Where are people going?
How are they getting
their information?
My biggest concern--
and it's not just
because of the recent
discussion of fake news.
My biggest concern is where
is news going to come from?
So I don't need a
gatekeeper to tell me
it's a left-leaning source
or a right-leaning source.
I need a gatekeeper to
vet to make sure at least
there are three sources
and that it's truth.
And I think we're at the point
now where Google is there.
Lots of others will be
there, that algorithms
are going to tell me
that [SNAPS] there's
something happening.
And I think for some
news, that's OK.
I mean, if I were
flying an airplane,
and I had to look for
an emergency landing,
and I could land in your
parking lot, and all of us
grabbed our phone, and
we start taking pictures.
This is nuts.
Look at the weather guy just
stepped out of an airplane.
So if that gets posted, and
somebody can assign high value
that 200 of us just said an
airplane landed in the Google
parking lot--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That's probably true.
CHUCK GAIDICA: --I don't don't
know that I need a reporter.
But I think for some things,
I'd like to have a voice.
And I think that's what
media now is struggling with.
Whose voice is it?
Where is it coming from?
And maybe in the future,
more importantly,
where is it going to come from?
If everything is autonomous,
how do I trust it?
I think that's a big
question for all of us here.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Right.
What are your colleagues
doing in the industry
if viewership is going down?
How are they adapting?
Are people moving to
online news sources?
Or how are they staying
in the industry?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, traditional
media is looking at--
well, for instance, WDIV has
the strongest web presence
in the state, with
ClickOnDetroit.com.
I think they're all looking
at what does new media mean?
How do we reach out
through social media?
What is the value of Google
and Facebook and Instagram?
So it's everything has
a little different play.
And I think the trouble
traditional media
is having is trying to figure
out how to monetize it.
So you could do it.
We can do all kinds
of cool stuff.
And we can buy or maybe for
free get programs or platforms
that can do cool stuff.
But you can, as you know, if
you're not being productive,
if all day long all you're
doing is posting on Facebook,
I'm not sure that all
those people are going
to come translate into viewers.
So I think that's what they're
struggling with is part of what
they're struggling with.
So there's maybe
a declining scale
in terms of financial resources
that are coming in to stations.
And not just traditional TV.
It's really anybody.
The company that I work for
was owned by the Washington
Post/Newsweek Magazine.
Post/Newsweek--
historic company.
They're the guys that
investigated the Nixon White
House.
This is "The Washington Post"--
not the one we know today--
"Newsweek" magazine.
Eventually, they sold
"Newsweek" magazine for $1,
for really the name.
And the company
that bought it had
to inherit about $300 million,
I think is what the number was,
of debt.
And several years later, they
sold "The Washington Post,"
mainly for its name.
And so now we're
divested of anything
that's traditional print
because who in here is reading
a magazine or a newspaper?
It's not typical.
So I've watched in my career
my very eyes things not just
diminish in terms of their
importance and their impact
but just, I mean, vanish--
in a practical sense.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: OK.
Can you give us a little
bit of inside experience
of what it's like working
for the television station?
Are there any particular stories
that stand out to you as, wow,
the normal person in the world
wouldn't experience this?
Or waking up at 2:00 AM to
go get ready for a program.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Tell us a
little bit what that's like.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Traditional
broadcasting-- well,
really any broadcasting,
although today you
didn't require me to wear
makeup and pantyhose.
But that's the-- so for guys,
that's the hardest part is--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Putting on makeup.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
The other part of this
that's really interesting
is the behind-the-scenes stuff.
The people who come
in, who not so much
are requiring
special-colored jelly
beans and their private water.
But you do have some of those
demands of guests that come in.
The most fun I've
ever had is probably
[CHUCKLES] kids and animals.
I don't think that
that ever changes.
Look, Steve Harvey has
a whole new show now,
working with kids.
And I was out live once at the
airport doing the weather live.
And I really memorize
what I'm going to do.
I did the forecast, so
I ad lib everything.
I just talk for three minutes.
And they tell me,
shut up, and I'm done.
And so I had notes.
I put them on top
of a little monitor.
And I'm working
with pygmy goats.
It's just part of the deal.
And so--
[CHUCKLING]
--here are these little
poodle-size animals.
And my paper blew off the top.
You couldn't see it on camera.
I was in full-screen graphics.
But the paper blew
off, settled down,
and all these goats came running
over and ate my piece of paper
like they were piranhas.
And I started laughing.
And it was the only
time in my career
where I just couldn't
finish what I was doing.
I said, back to you.
And I just kept laughing.
I couldn't stop.
So there was that.
I've never had major bloopers.
Like, a set hasn't
fallen down or, you know.
But access is probably
the most fun thing.
So I never would have gone on
expeditions to the rain forest
or in Peru or top of Mt.
Kilauea if I weren't
in the media.
It wasn't because it was me.
It was because I happened to be
following a kid from Detroit.
Never in a million
years could I have
flown through a hurricane
with the hurricane hunters
because I was in TV news.
Never in a million
years could I have
flown with the Blue Angels.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: You
were in the cockpit with--
CHUCK GAIDICA: In the
cockpit with the guy.
And he came out.
Who's seen "Top Gun"?
Have you seen-- oh.
So I'm with a Top Gun pilot.
This kid is-- he's 26 years old.
He walks out, and
he's about ready
to retire from being
a Top Gun pilot.
He walks out.
Everybody snaps to attention.
And he's got an assistant.
And they put me in
the seat behind him.
And the assistant
kid reaches in,
and pulls the lever down,
and locks it into place--
a big red lever.
I said, what are you doing?
He said, I've just
armed your chair.
I said, with what?
He said, with the equivalent
of two sticks of dynamite.
So whatever you do, don't
push that red button.
I said, trust me.
I'm not touching any red button.
But if you've seen
the movie, when--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Eject?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah, the
ejection and the canopy
didn't come off.
So I'm with this
Blue Angels pilot--
Willow Run Airport, Ypsilanti.
And he got permission
to fly along
the top of the ground, maybe
50 feet off the ground.
He got to the edge
of the runway.
And he said, when
I say, pull, pull--
on the second pull,
I'm going vertical.
I'm going to hit
the afterburner.
We were from ground zero to
22,000 feet in 20 seconds.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: It was awesome.
But you know, I
go to Cedar Point.
I've done Cedar Point and Kings
Island in Ohio in the same week
because I like roller coasters.
So for me, it was a blast.
And then he did an
inverted barrel loop.
And I never knew that you
could see passing out.
I always thought when people
pass out, they just pass out.
So I see it coming
because we're upside down,
doing about 2 and 1/2 gs.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
And you passed out.
CHUCK GAIDICA: No, almost.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: [CHUCKLES]
CHUCK GAIDICA: No, the good
news is I didn't puke because--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: That's good.
CHUCK GAIDICA: --it would
have been the assistant who
had to clean it up.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Was it televised?
CHUCK GAIDICA: No.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: From
the cockpit, was it--
CHUCK GAIDICA:
There were little,
like little lipstick
cameras in the cockpit.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Uh-huh.
CHUCK GAIDICA: But that
kind of cool stuff,
for me, because I
was in the media--
being able to go on expeditions
with world-class researchers--
I mean, I'm sitting in
the middle of the Amazon
in Peru with Dr. Bob
Ballard, the guy who
discovered the "Titanic."
And I'm shooting the
breeze with this guy,
who was like, you know.
He's on Nat Geo.
I mean, for me, it's been like
being a kid in a candy store.
That's probably some of
the most fun was just
being able to have access to--
I'm standing in the White House.
And when I was in
Little Rock, Arkansas,
I used to draw a
cartoon character.
If I did the weather, I slid
open a secret little door,
and there was a
piece of paper there.
And I'd draw
cartoon named Gusty.
You know, they
wanted to kill Gusty.
And I said, I'm not
going to kill Gusty
because everybody will hate me.
So I'll do Gusty.
So I can draw a stick figure
with the best of them.
So I drew this stick figure.
Now fast forward.
I'm in the White House with
President Bill Clinton.
And I'm standing in
a receiving line.
And the guy in the
dress blues comes up.
And he whispers
in my ear, you've
got 15 seconds
with the president.
Make it count.
And I'm thinking,
ah, what do you say?
I don't know.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Were you nervous?
CHUCK GAIDICA: I was.
So I walk up.
And he was in Little Rock
when I was in Little Rock.
And I walked up.
I said, Mr. President, I'm
one of the weather people
who used to draw Gusty.
And he looked at me.
He went, (BILL CLINTON
VOICE) oh, I remember you.
And I'm thinking, you do not.
You do not.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: He did?
Oh, wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: But people
said he had a sharp memory.
But I think he was
just being nice.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Maybe he did.
CHUCK GAIDICA:
Yeah, maybe he did.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
It's possible.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yeah.
And you became known
for these Cuddle Alerts
when the cold winter came in.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: And actually
wrote a book about Cuddle Bear.
CHUCK GAIDICA: I did.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
Is that right?
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, when
you hug somebody or cuddle
with somebody, you
release oxytocin.
So it's called the
cuddle hormone.
I didn't name it.
And so I was in
Little Rock, Arkansas.
And in Little Rock--
that was my stop
before Detroit--
it was boring.
Winters were boring.
There was never any snow.
If there was, they'd kick
the kids out of school
when there was like
a half inch of snow.
And I thought, what am I going
to do to make the winter fun?
I grew up in Chicago.
We get blizzards--
2 feet of snow,
drifts up the side of the house.
So I thought, I'm going
to come up with a fun
way of describing cold.
So I came up with Cuddle Alert.
I eventually had
it service marked.
And so then I start issuing
every night when I moved
to Detroit a Cuddle Alert.
When it got colder than
average, I would say,
you can cuddle with somebody
you know or don't know.
It's all platonic.
And--
[CHUCKLING]
--it kind of stuck.
And so then, moving forward, I
wrote a book-- children's book.
And I wrote another book on
cuddling, more the science
of it.
And--
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Kind of
tongue-in-cheek science anyway.
And out of that grew
a little teddy bear.
And while my wife urged me
to make this a nonprofit--
I probably should have.
I didn't because I
never made any money.
I wound up losing money on it.
But I took all the
profits from the books.
And I put them into teddy bears.
And we gave away about
8,000 teddy bears
to first responders.
Like if a ambulance pulled
up and saw a kid in a car
accident, they could reach in
the cab and hand them a bear.
And so that was pretty
cool to be able to do that.
So that's been the
fun part of trying
to do good is find ways
to media, old school,
writing a book-- how do I put it
all together and do something?
And all of a sudden, I wake up,
and there are 8,000 teddy bears
in the hands of kids.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
That's wonderful.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Awesome.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: You may
have also played matchmaker
with those Cuddle Alerts, too.
You never know.
CHUCK GAIDICA: I've been told.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: The viewers.
I've been told.
I actually have had
people walk up and say--
they point at
their kids and say,
this kid is a product
of a Cuddle Alert.
[CHUCKLING]
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Wow.
OK, yeah.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah, I know.
I'm not paying for college.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yeah,
serious business here.
CHUCK GAIDICA: I'm really
happy, but you know.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: So you
have a big responsibility
being on air.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Well, I
didn't realize I did.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ: Yeah, so.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.
MARC DE SCHWEINITZ:
OK, well, thank you.
CHUCK GAIDICA: Yeah.